Speaker 1: All right, let's let's.
Speaker 2: Talk about some stuff.
Many of you sent me clips of this sort of coming
out party interview that former Democratic
Congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard did on the Joe
Rogan program. And it's it's really pretty bad.
One of the things that was just bad about it
is this cat litter box story again rears its
ugly head. This is a story that has been repeated
so many times now about a teacher who installed a
litter box for a student who identifies as
a cat. And it's like, are we? We're still
telling this debunked story. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: There's kids ready for this.
My friend, his wife is a schoolteacher and
she works at a school that had to install a
litter box in the girl's room because there
is a girl who's a fairy who identifies as
an animal and her mother badgered the school
until they agreed to put a litter box in one
of the stalls. So this girl goes in to the litter
rooone morem or to the girl's room? The litter.
Speaker 2: Room that's genius.
Speaker 3: And urinates or whatever. I don't know
if she poops in it. That's pretty gross. Yeah, we
all like if you could teach your cat. By the way,
here's the thing. If you could teach your cat
to use the toilet, you would. Mm hmm. Okay.
Yeah. Like you don't want a box of piss in your
house, is the word. I like cats my whole life.
It's the worst thing about having cats. You got
to clean that box of piss every day. Yeah, well,
it's the greatest thing about dogs.
Speaker 2: All right.
Again, it's always like this friend. That
friend. Okay, what school exactly is this
happening at? Because it's already been debunked
multiple times. Nebraska Lawmaker Apologizes For
Debunked Litter Box Claim. A Nebraska state
lawmaker apologized after he publicly cited
a persistent but debunked rumor, alleging that
schools were putting litter boxes in bathrooms
to accommodate children who self-identify as
cats. That was Senator Bruce Bass Thalmann.
That's from March. There's another one
of these stories. Reuters Fact Check.
Michigan School District did not place litter
boxes in student restrooms. This was from
January. Social media users are sharing a video of
a midland Public School Board of Education meeting
where a community member says litter boxes are in
bathrooms for students who identify as furries.
And that's also not true. How could anyone really
still believe this at this point? Then they get
into a conversation about DeSantis. And, you
know, the sort of slippery thing about to see
is everything is always couched sort of like we
got to escape the two party system, the duopoly.
It's not working. Yeah, almost all of us agree
with that. But then to come to something like,
well, the Santos is the most reasonable in that
context, that doesn't really make any sense.
Speaker 3: If they had someone like Ron DeSantis,
who seems to be like the most reasonable among
the potential candidates, why he seems to
be, you know, a pretty no nonsense guy. Not
without his flaws, but it he's more reasonable
than anything that I'm seeing on the left.
Speaker 4: What?
Speaker 2: What? Then anything you're
seeing on the left. Look, I mean, listen, just
in a sort of totally banal and milquetoast way.
How is dissent is more reasonable than just
like Josh SHAPIRO in Pennsylvania? I mean,
it's he's he's too reasonable. It's too
often too milquetoast. You got to vote
for him over Mastriano because he's he's so
reasonable. There's just nothing controversial.
Speaker 3: DeSantis Yeah, at least with his
the way he handled COVID. Yeah. You know,
it's just, it's one of those things where
as it's all playing out, there's this sense
of hopelessness because there's not like a
clearly defined path where this country's
ship gets righted. It's like I just see a lot
of chaos and and a lot of confusion and a lot of
infighting. And I don't know how this plays out.
Speaker 2: And this is the tricky thing about
these conversations. Which is it? They they don't
wrongly identify certain issues. The infighting is
insane. The division is insane. But it's insane
because there's one side that has gone insane,
making demonstrably false claims about
everything, about the 2020 election,
about vaccines, about trans people, about
foreign policy, about so and so. DeSantis What.
Speaker 3: Doesn't? It doesn't seem like
there's a real clear, oh, is our path to sanity.
You're right. And I think the first
step towards that path, though,
is people recognizing what the insanity is.
Speaker 2: Right. And they're not. If you listen
to Tulsi because she's telling you the insanity
is woke elitism of a cabal, an anti-white racism,
and who else knows? I don't even remember what
else she said in that wacky video on Tuesday.
Speaker 3: And and the problems.
And I think that more and more, these
things these things are coming to light.
I can tell you I mean, I know there are a
lot of Democrats that feel the same kind of
frustration that I feel with the Democratic Party
leadership quietly. Yes. Yeah. There's a lot of
quiet disagreement where people are just like,
I don't know, I'm not voting for Trump, but what
the fuck are we doing? Right. And I think there's
there's there's that in the Republican Party as
well. Yeah. And so I think that that creates yeah.
Speaker 2: So quite literally now the epitome of
the enlightened centrist. And then
just lastly on this, talking about
the Russian invasion of Ukraine and well,
let's just watch this first and then discuss.
Speaker 3: What things like funding
the Ukraine war with Russia. Please
explain to people what that means and why why
we're sending so much money over to Ukraine.
So so let's start with with that. Let's start
with the military industrial complex. What is
it? Who is it? It is these massive defense
corporations who make all these different
weapons systems from the smallest to the
most powerful nuclear weapons and missiles.
Speaker 2: So Tulsi goes down the road of military
industrial complex. Now, there's no greater
critique of the military industrial complex
than me. But what you have to understand here
is that this isn't really the issue when it comes
specifically to Ukraine. You could have a general
conversation and say, should we be doing foreign
aid? Should we be doing foreign aid with weaponry?
If so, what types of countries should we support
or not? But the focus now when it's like, listen,
the Ukrainians are the victims of an act of
aggression by Putin and they are trying to defend
their country. And that's why with Ukraine, we
are sending stuff that we already have and other
countries are doing the same. But to make it all
of a sudden about the military industrial complex
now with Ukraine really misses the point of that
particular engagement. And again, it's not about,
oh, tools is a Russian agent or whatever. No, it's
not about that. It's this is exactly the ideology
that plays right into Putin's hands, which
is he's the guy doing the war of aggression.
And the focus becomes, why are we sending
anything to Ukraine? Even though it's pennies,
it's a drop in the bucket, what is being sent to
Ukraine? And they are genuinely trying to defend
themselves. So all the normal stuff from TLC on
the Rogan program and it is very disappointing.